wow andrew cuomo's life blew up today
he's a
very weird guy you know that if you
watch him on television if you ever talk
to him in person
and if you have we apologize for the
experience then you know for certain
andrew cuomo has some secrets earlier
this year remember several women accused
him of sexual misconduct and the weird
thing is the media treated that like a
bigger scandal than the fact that andrew
cuomo caused the deaths of thousands of
elderly people in nursing homes in his
state and then cover up that was no big
deal
but saying something naughty to one of
his staff he's got to leave
office we're not defending either one
but proportion please
now at the time como denied the
allegations he emphasized as he has for
years
that he's a big believer in the me too
movement of course he is
but today the office of new york's
attorney general completed its
investigation into andrew cuomo's serial
creepiness
and they found that cuomo had violated
quote multiple state and federal laws
the investigation found that governor
andrew cuomo
sexually harassed current and former
new york state employees by engaging in
unwelcome
and non-consensual touching and making
numerous offensive comments
of a suggestive and sexual nature the
governor's
pattern of sexually harassing behavior
was not limited
to members of his own staff
but extended to other state employees
including a state trooper who served
on his protective detail some suffered
through unwanted touching
and grabbing of their most intimate body
parts
the governor hugged executive assistant
number one
and reached under her blouse to grab her
breast
this was the culmination of a pattern of
inappropriate sexual conduct
including numerous close and intimate
hugs where the governor held her so
closely
that her breasts were pressed against
his body and he sometimes ran his hands
up and down his her back while he did so
there were also several occasions on
which the governor grabbed her butt
wasn't joe biden accused of all of that
credibly i guess we're pretending that
didn't happen but we care about this
one thing we learned andrew cuomo is not
against defunding the police he wants to
have sex with them or at least one of
them
now just to be clear you can find the
little sexual commissars on your screen
that you just saw repulsive
and at the same time find andrew cuomo
repulsive it's okay to dislike everybody
involved
in fact you probably should the ag's
report also found that governor cuomo
appeared to be sexually attractive
to his emmy statue how's that for weird
two witnesses also this is a quote
recounted that during a meeting the
governor
looked at his emmy which he had won in
november of 2020
and put in his albany office and said
something to the effect of quote
look at her figure isn't she buxom
he's a total creep i mean for real but
you knew that
another exhibit in the report appears to
show chris cuomo of cnn drafted a
statement for his brother because that's
totally normal
which his brother ultimately used so
here you have cnn the news network
flacking for the governor of new york to
defend himself against sexual harassment
this afternoon andrew cuomo responded to
the ag's report he again denied that he
did anything wrong
he did not claim anti-italian bias
though he has claimed that many times in
the past
he did make it clear he's not resigning
he also showed a slideshow of himself
kissing people including al gore
and said his his gestures of affection
have been
wildly misinterpreted i want you to know
directly from me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
i am 63 years old i've lived my entire
adult life in public view
that is just not who i am
and that's not who i have ever been
now we didn't show the tape but we just
want to be totally clear that the video
the slideshow that cuomo put on the
screen
showed him hugging al gore but not
reaching up under gore's shirt to grab
his man boobs that that did not happen
we didn't know if it happened but he
didn't show it today
anyway we're not quite sure what to make
all of this francie hicks
is she's a former federal prosecutor she
joins us tonight
francis thanks so much for coming on how
would you assess what we've just learned
about governor creepo well tucker i
think governor cuomo is in a lot of
trouble i think it's pretty convenient
that he says that's not who i
am that is a classic non-denial denial
that we hear
from sex offenders and at the same time
he empathized with some of the women
who've made these accusations
he called them a liar you can't have it
both ways and one of the women who was a
victim
a prior victim of sexual assault he
indicated that he felt so much sympathy
for her
the condensation the condescension
dripping
from him was really pretty disgusting
the most interesting thing i think
tucker is that
everyone talks about sexual harassment
and an unwanted touching
but grabbing someone in their breast
area or their butt
an unwanted touching those are batteries
assaults
and sexual batteries and those are
crimes that's very different
from a civil case which is what the
attorney general has talking about today
so i i hate to borrow the the words of
the metoo movement but what this
establishes
is a pattern over time of hostile
behavior of sexually aggressive behavior
and it's happening
in the office of one of the most liberal
governors in america now
ask any woman who's dated across the
island should tell you that liberal men
are horrible to date they mistreat women
i mean that's just that's just true
they're bad boyfriends
um across the board but why didn't so
i'm not surprised that he did this but
why did
nobody in the office report this until
now why did it take years to find this
out
well you know that's an interesting
question tucker it's all about cover-up
and i think it all has to do with power
when you've got someone in a powerful
position like governor he's been talked
about many times
as a presidential candidate even women
who are supposed
to support other women would rather run
those women down
for their own careers because they're
looking for their own
career advancement and so they're
willing to protect the governor and
by the way what he said about kissing al
gore and being in the public eye
is a ridiculous excuse when you when you
consider
that sexual assault sexual battery and
harassment
are not crimes that would ever take
place in the public
eye and isn't it convenient that he has
built for himself
a touchy reputation my question is did
he build that touchy reputation
for himself so that he could claim later
that these were all misinterpreted
touching and that he's just a very
affectionate man
yeah and and by the way i kissed al gore
is not a defense it's an admission of
guilt i mean even tipper had enough of
that over time
you know what i mean like that's that's
gross that sort of i kissed al gore
i'm not weird no you're weird you're
very weird francie hicks you were not
weird you were insightful we're glad to
have you
thank you thanks tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else